every time a bell rings an angel gets
its wings it's an iconic line from it's
a wonderful life and even if you don't
believe in angels it is a pleasant image
after all angels are the embodiment of
goodness and light so an angel getting
its wings has to be a good thing right
well as anyone who's ever eaten one too
many christmas cookies can tell you it's
possible to have too much of a good
thing even something that sounds like
the embodiment of all things good in
theory can become deadly when taken to
the extreme that is where scp-469
also known as the many-winged angel
comes in this angel-like creature is
anything but innocent and in fact it has
been responsible for multiple deaths of
scp foundation personnel during its
captivity
scp-469 may be deadly but it is also
undeniably beautiful in a mysterious
ethereal way when first seen it appears
to be nothing more than a massive pile
of pristine white feathers like
something out of a pillow commercial the
pile measures 24 feet in diameter and
weighs at least two tons however like
many of the entities contained within
the walls of the foundation's countless
containment sites all is not as it seems
with 469 what looks at first glance to
be a pile of feathers is in fact a dense
curled mass of giant wings the wings
vary in size from the tiny wingspan of a
sparrow to the staggering 3.6 meter
wingspan of the wandering albatross the
one thing they have in common is their
plumage with each wing being covered
with the same glossy white feathers the
foundation was able to perform a series
of x-rays on the massive wings revealing
a skeletal structure beneath the
feathers like those of a bird the wing's
bones are hollow however they are
unnaturally soft and flexible allowing
for a range of motion that no known bird
possesses this accounts for the
curvature of the wings and their ability
to coil tightly into each other the
x-ray also provided the first and only
recorded glimpse at the creature hiding
underneath all the feathers at the
center of the layers upon layers of
wings is a humanoid creature curled into
a fetal position in defiance of the laws
of natural anatomy every single wing
appears to be fused to this creature's
spine how would it be able to move under
the weight of these wings or even if it
could is as of yet unknown the first
foundation personnel lost to
scp-469 were d-class personnel d-112 and
d-624
who were sent in to investigate the
nature of the creature an attempt to
contact the humanoid entity identified
on the x-rays
112-624 entered the room equipped with
gloves and protective eye gear as
scientists watched the situation unfold
on a monitor on a video feed no one
expected much to come with the encounter
the working hypothesis was the layers of
feathers would simply be too thick to
get through without seriously damaging
the bones it would be a fairly
uneventful experiment or so they thought
112 approached
scp-469 first and attempted to part a
section of its feathers with his hands
as 624 stood back and observed the
moment his fingertips touched the
feathers a rustling sound filled the
room the feathers began to quiver
shaking as if all waking up at once from
a deep slumber suddenly in the blink of
an eye the hundreds and hundreds of
wings unfurled and pulled one one two
into their depths he was swept into a
swirl of feathers and within seconds he
had disappeared from view completely
though 624 on the scientists watching on
their monitor could no longer see him
they could certainly hear him from the
moment the wings pulled him into the sea
of feathers one one two had begun to
scream in agony his screams persisted
growing louder and more desperate even
as the voice cracked and grew weak 624
stood frozen in place with fear and
shock 624 was ordered to attempt to
retrieve 112 from the feathers but made
no move to do so he simply stared at the
feathers eyes wide face pale as the pain
shrieks of his colleague bounced off the
sterile white walls of the containment
room a guard called over the intercom
threatening to terminate 624 if he did
not attempt to remove 112 from scp-469
grasp this warning seemed to shock 624
back into action and he made a run for
the center feathers arms up to protect
his face again the sound of rustling as
the feathers began to quake the wings
unfurled once more and 624 did not even
have a chance to turn back before he was
pulled in to meet the same dismal fate
as the other d-class his screams of pain
joined 1-1-2 as the scientists watching
over the monitor could do nothing to
help them as the two men cried out in
pain and horror from within their winged
prisons something began to happen that
the scientists had never seen before the
feathers started to shake again faster
than before and at first the wings
appeared to be unfolding again upon
second look though it was clear they
hadn't moved there were simply more of
them now as the men continued to scream
more feathers appeared the wings
stretching out and elongating as new
wings sprouted as if from nowhere
scp-469 appeared to be feeding on the
sound of their screams and using that
energy to expand it was only after
several long minutes when the screaming
finally stopped that the growth of the
wings did too at this point the wings
shifted again expelling the bodies of
112 and 624 from within its folds
dropping them limply on the ground
though their deaths were unfortunate the
loss of 112 and 624 did reveal some new
information about
scp-469 first that it could grow and
apparently needed to feed on sounds in
order to do so second that it was deadly
to humans and most likely to other
living things as well autopsies of one
one two and six two force corpses would
later reveal exactly what happened to
them and how scp-469
kills its prey though four 69s feathers
may look as though they would be soft to
the touch each feather is actually made
up of sharp barbs that are capable of
piercing clothing and skin these barbs
release a neurotoxin into the system
that activates every pain receptor in
the body of the victim the neurotoxin
present in these feathers has not been
identified anywhere else in nature but
is somewhat similar in structure and
function to the neurotoxins excreted by
the cone snail and in the bite of the
blue ringed octopus in addition to the
pain-inducing neurotoxin the feathers
also carry several unidentified
stimulant compounds where the neurotoxin
on its own would induce enough pain for
the affected party to pass out almost
immediately the stimulant served to keep
the victim conscious scp foundation
scientists posit that this is so that
469 can get as much noise in this case
in the form of screams out of its pain
as possible and achieve maximum growth
before the captive creature dies or goes
into shock further experiments confirm
this theory and show that scp-46
will react similarly when exposed to any
living creature capable of making a
sound and experiencing pain not just
humans non-living matter though
including dead animals elicit no
response from 469. additional
experiments were then undertaken that
involved applying various different
sounds in order to test their effect on
scp-469's growth though it feeds on any
sounds produced in its presence it seems
to respond most strongly to musical
sounds exhibiting a particularly strong
response to classical music no sound
elicits a stronger reaction from this
creature however than the sound of
ringing bells it is rumored that when a
bell was wrong in the presence of 469
the humanoid at the center of the
feathers is said to have moved for the
first time on record apparently whatever
is at the center appeared to wake up and
unfurl its wings revealing itself but
unfortunately all security footage of
this incident has been white and the
data has been expunged from the record
leaving the creature's true form a
mystery you may be remembering that four
members of foundation personnel on
record were lost to scp-469
and that only two have been mentioned so
far the second pair of casualties
resulted when the foundation attempted
to terminate
scp-469 believing that there was no more
scientific benefit to keeping it alive
or at least that the possible benefits
did not outweigh the risks it was
ordered that
scp-469 be terminated by any means
necessary two skilled personnel dr jones
and dr smith were sent into the
containment facility in hazmat gear
armed with several sharp instruments
they were to attempt to use these to cut
through the forest of feathers and soft
bones until they could reach the
humanoid at the center it was presumed
that once they did and the creature no
longer had the protection of its
poisonous feathers that it would be
relatively easy to kill they could not
have been more wrong
dr jones approached the dense cover of
feathers with a pair of sharpened
gardening shears while dr smith opted
for a machete at first the strategy
appeared to be working dr jones made
several quick cuts with feathers
fluttering to the floor and sticking to
the hazmat suit as dr smith slashed into
the feathers with his machete making
similarly promising progress however the
situation quickly took a turn for the
worse when dr jones dropped her sheers
and let out a blood-curdling scream the
feathers had taken a little longer to
get through the suit to her skin but
somehow they managed to find a way just
the same smith grabbed jones and
attempted to make a break for it but he
was too slow and far too close to the
feathers already the wings wrapped
around them and swallowed them both up
leaving the researchers outside helpless
to do anything but listen to their
screams and wait for them to go quiet
after several minutes they finally did
and now larger
scp-469 had officially claimed another
two foundation personnel obviously 469
could not be terminated using any
methods that would place the responsible
personnel within its grasp that was
simply too risky so the foundation
selected a team of d-class personnel to
attempt to burn the feathers with an
array of flamethrowers though the
feathers were vulnerable to fire and
began to blacken and disintegrate on
contact the sound of the flames being
expelled was loud enough to feed
scp-469 its growth was so quick in
response to the noise that the fire
could not keep up with the amount of new
feathers and wings being produced by the
same time the flamethrowers ran out of
propellant 469 was the same size it had
been when they started other
terminations have been discussed
including the possibility of submerging
the entire creature in a highly
corrosive acid but so far this has not
yet been attempted whatever they end up
trying it is clear that nothing that
produces a significant amount of noise
will be able to kill 469 so where is it
now what's become of this perverse angel
with the never-ending wings currently it
is kept in an airtight soundproof
chamber where nothing can trigger the
growth of any more wings so what is it
an angel a demon a twisted mutated bird
of some kind it is entirely possible
that we will never know but it's a
wonderful life had something right even
by accident every time a bell rings
something twisted and deadly though it
may be
gets its wings now check out
scp-096 look at a picture of the shy guy
in space the shy guy questions and
theories and
scp-082 ferdinand the cannibal for more
foundation mysteries unraveled